So today we're going to dig into
this really fascinating and kind
of weird political shift that's
happening in America.
We're seeing national symbols
get fought over, reclaimed and
maybe maybe even reinvented
right before our eyes.
Let's get into it.
And, you know, this whole idea
is perfectly framed by this
powerful thought from the
philosopher Jean Paul Sartre.
He's basically warning us that a
performance, if you keep it up
long enough, can become your
reality.
Seriously, keep this quote in
your back pocket because it is
the key to everything we're
about to unpack.
So what is this strange thing
that's happening?
Well, all of a sudden, the
American left seems to be
embracing patriotic symbols that
it's treated with suspicion for
a long time.
You know, the flag quotes from
the founders talk about our
Republic.
The analysis we're exploring
today offers two really powerful
and competing theories for why
this is going on, and we are
going to break them both down.
All right, So First things
first, let's talk about the idea
that connects both of these
theories.
Performance.
Is this a genuine change of
heart, or is it a calculated
political act, you know, a role
being played on a national
stage?
Now, the analysis we're looking
at says this goes way deeper
than just, you know, hypocrisy.
The idea is that an entire class
of people, the moral managers,
are trying on a patriotic
costume, and the performance is
so convincing, it might just
become real.
Think of it this way.
It's like an atheist who
memorizes all the church hymns
just to fit in, but then one day
he's singing and realizes he
actually feels something.
The performance becomes the
belief.
And what's really interesting
here is how this plugs right
into Sartre's concept of bad
faith.
And get this, it's not about
lying to other people.
It's about lying to yourself.
It's that moment when you play a
role, a waiter, a patriot,
whatever, so completely that you
forget you ever chose to play it
in the first place.
And the argument is, America has
a long history of doing this,
pretending to be a nation of
equals, and in doing so
imperfectly becoming one.
Pretending isn't just a lie,
it's a creative act.
OK, so let's get into our first
theory, which the source calls
the Great Patriotic Heist.
The argument here is that the
left isn't rediscovering
patriotism because it feels all
warm and fuzzy.
Nope.
Instead, it's a strategic theft
born from a sheer panic over
losing control of the national
story.
To really get this theory, we
got to do a quick Philosophy 101
with a guy named Hegel.
He had this idea called the
dialectic.
It's a pattern of change.
You start with a big dominant
idea.
That's the thesis.
That idea then creates an
opposing force, the antithesis,
and the conflict between those
two resolves into something
totally new, a synthesis, which
then becomes the new thesis.
And on and on it goes.
In this slide, it lays out
exactly how that heist theory
uses this pattern.
The thesis was that kind of
technocratic moral order of the
20 tens, the antithesis.
Well, that was the populist
revolt against it.
And so the new synthesis,
according to this theory, is the
left trying to absorb all that
populist energy by stealing its
patriotic symbols.
So what's the end result here?
Well, according to this theory,
it's something called synthetic
patriotism.
This isn't your messy,
spontaneous love of country.
This is a managed corporate
brand of national pride.
The source even calls it the
United States of HR, where
freedom basically means having a
safe space to perform all the
correct virtues.
And here's the big warning that
comes with this whole heist
idea.
The danger isn't that the
performance fails.
No, the real danger is that it
actually works, that it becomes
a kind of patriotism that's
bureaucratic, that demands
compliance and is enforced from
the top down.
A patriotism of policy, not of
passion.
OK, so let's switch gears and
look at the second theory.
This one offers a totally
different take, the reinvention.
This perspective argues that
what looks like a cynical
performance is actually
something much more hopeful, the
awkward but totally necessary
first step of civic renewal.
The big idea here is that
sometimes belief follows the
ritual, right?
Like we learned the songs before
we actually feel the lyrics.
This theory says America has to
act patriotic to remember how to
be patriotic.
So what one side calls mimicry,
this side calls developing civic
muscle memory.
And this timeline, it really
puts this whole moment into
historical context.
It shows that, hey, the meaning
of patriotism, it's never been
set in stone.
It's been a form of rebellion, a
kind of collectivist duty, a
target of counter cultural
revolt.
And now what they're calling a
reclamation project.
The flag has always been
contested, ground redefined by
every single generation.
So why might this be a real
reinvention and not just a ploy?
Well, this theory gives a few
key reasons.
For one, it's an admission that
guilt alone can't hold a country
together.
It's an attempt to expand the
American story to include more
voices.
And crucially, it recognizes
that politics is about emotion
and narrative.
I mean, you can't govern a story
you refuse to even tell.
All right, So now we've got 2
very different ways of looking
at the exact same thing.
One sees a cynical heist, the
other sees a sincere
reinvention.
Let's put them side by side and
see the two, well, really
different futures they predict
for America.
This chart just lays it all out.
The fundamental divide.
Is the motivation a panic to
control the story or is it
actual moral growth?
Is the whole process just a
branding exercise or is it a
form of civic education?
And look at the potential
dangers.
The heist theory fears a world
of sincerity by decree, while
the reinvention theory warns of
a preachy, know it all kind of
patriotism.
So look, this whole debate, it's
about way more than just
political strategy.
This is about the fundamental
question of how America tells
its own story and who gets to be
the author of that story.
And this might be the most
profound take away of all.
The goal might not be to find
the one true meaning of American
patriotism.
Instead, maybe the story of
America is this endless cycle of
argument, performance, and
redefinition, the exhaustion we
all feel from the constant
debate.
Maybe that isn't a sign of
failure.
Maybe it's a sign that the
system is actually working.
And think about it, this process
has been going for almost 250
years.
The central argument here is
that the flag and the Republic
itself have only survived
precisely because they remain
contested ground, meaning
different things to different
people.
This really gets to the heart of
the more optimistic Take the
reinvention theory, the fact
that even the critics can
eventually reclaim national
symbols and find a way to love
the country in their own
language.
That's not a weakness.
The argument is that's the
nation's greatest, most
resilient strength.
So in the end, we're left to
wrestle with this one last
really provocative question.
Is this new patriotism a
performance or a genuine
reinvention?
And that forces us to choose
which is worse, a slightly
artificial performed unity that
papers over our divisions, or
facing the terrifying truth of
just how deep those divisions
really run.
The answer, whatever it is, is
probably going to define the
next chapter of the American
story.